mesdames messieurs bonjour bon je vais
pas faire une démo très longue et pas
trop de place voici un appareil qui est
en train de modifier les règles du jeu
de la circulation urbaine
c'est un petit véhicule avec lequel je
suis venu aujourd'hui pour vous le
présentez déjà mais aussi parce que
c'est mon moyen de déplacement principal
j'habite à 14 kilomètres d'ici donc je
suis venu avec sa aujourd'hui j'imagine
que pour votre part vous êtes venus avec
des moyens plus traditionnels
peut-être en transports en commun en en
voiture en taxi peu importe des moyens
de déplacement en tout cas qui implique
certaines contraintes comme mes
prédécesseurs viennent de l'annoncer
donc perdre du temps dans les
embouteillages perdre du temps à
attendre un rer qui n'arrivent pas à
cause des d'un colis suspect par exemple
dans une gare ou encore passer du temps
collés les uns aux autres dans une rame
de métro bondée de monde
donc voilà des situations pas toujours
très agréables et bien je vous propose
de vous affranchir de tous ces problèmes
au quotidien qui rajoute du stress et de
la fatigue tous les jours où très
souvent en tout cas par ce moyen de
déplacement
alors comment ça fonctionne faut oser
monter dessus c'est vrai qu'au début ça
peut faire un peu peur et il faut se
laisser tomber en avant la machine en
fait faut lui faire confiance
elle va vous rattraper ce qui fait vous
allez avancé c'est une histoire de
centre de gravité
quand vous allez mettre du poids sur
l'avant de la machine ça va accélérer
vers l'avant quand vous allez mettre du
poids sur l'arrière ça va freiner voire
reculer si vous restez sur vos talons
voilà donc il ya plusieurs façons
d'utiliser ce moyen de déplacement
j'ai pas la zapette
alors certains s'en servent tout
simplement pour pour s'amuser ceux qui
vont aller dans les skypark pour faire
des petits sauts du freestyle faire des
figures techniques à plusieurs pour
rouler sur un pied faire de la marche
arrière
voir faire des figures acrobatiques tena
qui sont très forts car il va rouler sur
les mains après il ya ceux qui vont s'en
servir
plus classique pour faire plus de
simples balades pour visiter du pays
pour chasser les pokémon pour faire tout
ce que vous voulez et puis il ya ceux
qui vont s'en servir dans un but plus
extrêmes rouler à fond à fond la caisse
dans la forêt faire du tout terrain ça
se rapproche déjà un peu plus de mon
profil si vous regardez ma roue de plus
près elle est pas très propre j'aime
bien faire du cross dans la boue à fond
la caisse
voilà il en a même ça c'est un
finlandais qui fait de la roue dans la
neige carrément voilà donc tout hutin
tout un tas de façons de s'amuser avec
la roue électrique
moi je considère qu m
en plus d'être un une alternative
ludique au moyen de déplacement s'est
enfin c'est vraiment un véritable moyen
de déplacement qui va permettre de faire
vraiment de réelle distance un kilowatt
heure coûte 15 centimes d'électricité
j'ai les différents fournisseurs
sachant qu'avec un kilowatt heure vous
pouvez parcourir jusqu'à 80 kilomètres
sur ce genre d'appareil 6 alors j'ai 80
km réel c'est pas des données
constructeur bidon moi je suis moi je
suis facteur ils l'ont dit je suis je ne
suis pas commercial je vais pas vous
vendre un produit
je peux vous vendre des timbres si vous
voulez mais je vais pas vous vendre une
roue électrique je suis là en tant que
passionné pour partager cette passion et
vous donner envie éventuellement de de
réfléchir à un futur moyen de
déplacement en complément ou en
remplacement de vos moyens de
déplacement actuel alors donc je disais
15 centimes 80 km si on compare la
voiture pour faire la même distance ça
va vous coûter 50 fois plus cher en
carburant
sans parler de l'assurance l'entretien
les réparations les péages les parcs m
les contraventions éventuellement tout
ce qui va avec l'utilisation d'une
voiture sans parler évidemment que les
moteurs thermiques sont beaucoup plus
polluant et font du bruit
donc voilà ce genre d'appareil n'a pas
toutes ses contraintes
vous avez pas besoin de vous garez vous
n'avez pas besoin d'avoir une assurance
vous n'avez pas besoin de faire beaucoup
d'entretien celle ci je vient de
dépasser la barre des 10000 km sur le
compteur de cette roue dix mille
kilomètres j'ai jamais changer la
moindre pièce en a par le pneu qui
mériterait d'être peut-être changer un
moment donné parce que il ya un peu
lisse mais sinon à part ça c'est
vraiment quasiment pratiquement gratuit
à l'utilisation hormis le prix de
l'achat
d'ailleurs j'ai pas parler du prix de
c'est quand même des appareils qui
peuvent aller de six ans à 3000 euros
c'est pour ça que si on considère ça
comme une façon de s'amuser ça fait un
peu cher le jouer mais c'est pour ça que
moi je considère ça véritablement comme
comme un moyen de déplacement
alors c'est vraiment le moyen de
déplacement idéal pour faire tout ce que
vous avez à faire
que ce soit à léo faire des petites
courses au supermarché pour aller un
rendez vous voir des amis de la famille
dans la région ou bien aller au boulot
par exemple moi je vais au boulot
quotidiennement avec ma roue depuis deux
ans maintenant
avant j'allais en vélo c'était déjà la
roux prend moins de place dans mon
appartement
c'est moins encombrant c'est plus facile
à transporter dans les escaliers ça pèse
un peu lourd mais c'est toujours moins
moins embêtant apporté qu'un vélo
et puis j'ai ma petite séance de glisse
matinale avant d'aller travailler c'est
très agréable
un plaisir de glisse dans ce grand
terrain de jeu de la région parisienne
en plus le matin l'heure à laquelle je
pars il ya pas beaucoup de circulation
c'est vraiment un régal de pratiquer ce
moyen de déplacement et du coup j'arrive
au bureau beaucoup plus frais jeu avant
quand j'allais en vélo j'arrivais un peu
en transpirant parce que j'avais
tendance à partir en retard en plus donc
la roue électrique ça vraiment tout
changer et puis je peux la mettre à
recharger éventuellement sous ma
position de travail pendant que je bosse
ce qui me permet en plus de faire payer
l'employeur à ma place impeccable
donc voilà c'est vraiment pratique même
pour partir en vacances également ça
prend peu de place dans le coffre d'une
voiture où sous le siège dans le train
et puis arrivé à destination vous sortez
de la gare vous êtes libre vous pouvez
visiter des villes ou des régions
partout en france ou en europe
bien plus rapidement avec beaucoup plus
de liberté voilà moi j'ai fait un voyage
vous avez des images là derrière
je suis parti d'amsterdam et j'ai roulé
pas dans les pays bas la belgique la
france pendant 1600 km d'affilée en 18
jours j'ai rechargé sur 39 prise
électrique que je trouvais au fur et à
mesure sur mon chemin des prix ce que je
trouvais dans les restaurants où
j'allais manger dans les espaces publics
les les halls d'immeuble les comptes les
les placards edf un peu partout dans les
gares fin voilà c'était devenu un petit
jeu pour moi de flairer le courant
partout je pouvais le trouver une chasse
aux trésors grandeur nature à
l'électricité me permettant de continuer
mon aventure j'avais nommé ça cette
aventure j'irai chargé chez vous un clin
d'oeil à l'émission d'antoine de maximy
sur france 5
j'ai essayé moi aussi d'aller dormir
chez les gens ce qui n'a pas été
toujours évident j'ai fait quelques
nuits à la belle étoile à côté de ma
prise électrique
c'était ça le plus important la règle
numéro 1 avoir du courant pour pouvoir
continuer je m'étais fixé aussi comme
règle de ne pas aller à l'hôtel de ne
pas utiliser de moyen de déplacement
autre que marc ou parce que ça va
enlever un peu de charme à l'aventuré je
voulais faire quelque chose quand même
d'assez unique c'est un challenge est
donc je suis parvenu à atteindre cet
objectif grâce à des gens qui m'ont
accueilli sur la route parce que je
rédigeais un blog au fur et à mesure
pour raconter mais toute mésaventure et
puis il ya des gens qui m'ont contacté
par l'intermédiaire du blog ou les
réseaux sociaux ou autres pour me dire
tu passe près de chez moi si tu veux
bien dormir pour déjeuner aussi le midi
ou peu importe
en tout cas pour recharger mon véhicule
voilà donc ce voyage a bien prouvé que
c'était que ce que ça est que c'est un
véritable moyen de déplacement est aussi
en quelque sorte un outil social qui
permet d'aller rencontrer les gens quand
vous roulez là-dessus automatiquement il
ya partout dans la rue dans les parcs
il ya plein de gens qui vont par
curiosité venir vers vous pour
s'intéresser à votre machine
c'est génial votre truc ça s'appelle
comment ça s'achète tout ça coûte
combien
est ce que vous pouvez me faire essayer
donc sacré facilement un contact comme
ça avec le monde extérieur avec des gens
avec qui vous auriez peut-être pas
forcément parler si vous aviez été un
piéton ordinaire et donc voila moi j'ai
aussi rencontré pas mal de monde dans la
communauté des wheeler c'est comme ça
qu'on nous appelle les wheeler de paris
les wheeler de partout en france
des balades en organiser des balades
régulièrement nantes ou encore
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs de la même façon
qu'ils allaient rando roller il ya
maintenant les randos wheeler en quelque
sorte des balades de plusieurs dizaines
de kilomètres durant lesquelles on
s'arrête dans les bars pour recharger
les engins qui en ont le plus besoin
donc c'est aussi un prétexte pour aller
boire un p'tit coup entre amis
éventuellement là vous voyez des images
avec plus d'une centaine de personnes
ces des événements qui s'organise et de
temps en temps dans l'année le prochain
ce sera fin avril y aura plus de 250
personnes
ce qui prouve bien que c'est vraiment un
moyen de en train de se développer
fortement ces derniers temps
voilà donc un objet social en plus
d'être un moyen de déplacement une
alternative ludique au moyen de
déplacement j'ai fait un autre voyage
plus récemment cette fois ci c'était sur
le continent africain ça peut paraître
bizarre peut-être de partir avec sa en
afrique on avait fait un petit projet
humanitaire avec deux amis donc avant de
partir on avait créé une cagnotte sur
internet et on a atteint presque 3000
euros beaucoup plus que ce qu'on avait
imaginé et grâce à cet argent on a donc
pendant notre voyage au sénégal apporter
des choses aux gens notamment les
enfants talibés qui sont des orphelins
qui vivent de la mendicité et qui ont
été confiées à quelqu'un qui se charge
de leur éducation et donc on allait en
aide à ces gens là pour leur apporter
tout ce qu'ils avaient besoin donc des
matelas des cahiers des stylos des gros
sacs de 50 kg de riz du sucre du lait en
poudre
voilà donc on a répété ces actions là
plusieurs fois à travers notre périple
et donc ils étaient très contents de
nous voir arriver en plus sur ce genre
de petit appareil sacré pas mal de
surprises
on a traversé le pays dans des endroits
assez reculée où les gens n'avaient pas
forcément l'habitude de voir des
touristes déjà donc là le fait de voir
3,3 blanc arrivé chez eux désinstaller
surprenait un petit peu alors en plus
sur ce genre d'appareil je vous laisse
imaginer ça on a fait vraiment plein de
belles rencontres 1 partout là où vont
s'arrêter
c'était comme un espèce dément et à toul
tout le village qui se rassembler autour
de nous par curiosité pour voir ce qu'on
fout tu es ici avec sa voix est donc là
on a vraiment eu aucun mal pour le coup
à trouver des endroits pour pour dormir
pour poursuit pour manger pour recharger
nos véhicules
les gens étaient toujours ravi nous
accueillir chez eux malgré une pauvreté
omniprésente dans le pays
il était toujours très accueillants à
nous proposer de partager le repas avec
eux à nous proposer une petite pièce
pour passer la nuit
une prise électrique tout ce qui est
tout ce qu'il fallait pour pour notre
bonheur voilà est donc une belle une
belle aventure que vous pourrez suivre
si ça vous intéresse à travers une
petite web série prochainement une
petite web série qui sera diffusée sur
youtube saufs
forme de plusieurs épisodes d'ici la fin
du printemps probablement il ya beaucoup
d'imagés vous avez quelques unes des
images où nous voir rouler sur ces
chemins en terre rouge nous avait
beaucoup demander d'ailleurs avant de
partir vous allez faire comment pour
rouler dans le sable là bas vous allez
faire comment pour trouver du courant
vous allez faire comment je me posais un
peu les questions moi aussi parce que
j'avais jamais mis les pieds au sénégal
finalement on n'a pas eu de problème
particulier
les routes sont plutôt en bon état la
circulation parfois un peu dangereuse
mais on avait ces chemins là où roulent
les charrettes habituellement qui était
très agréable pour nous pour se balader
et concernant le courant n'a pas eu de
problème non plus les les installations
électriques faisait parfois un petit peu
peur
les normes ne sont pas les mêmes qu'en
europe mais le courant était au rendez
vous donc on a pu avancer à travers le
pays
voilà donc pour cette aventure hors du
commun
j'espère que tout ça vous a donné envie
de vous convertir éventuellement à ce
nouveau mode de déplacement sans
forcément aller à l'extrême comme ça en
traversant des pays entiers mais pour
vos déplacements quotidiens en milieu
urbain je pense que c'est vraiment un
moyen de déplacement absolument géniale
qui va vous procurer beaucoup de plaisir
qui va vous faire faire des rencontres
qui va vous faire gagner de l'argent du
temps donc voilà pourquoi est ce que je
suis venu aujourd'hui pour vous partager
cette passion
une petite anecdote pas ce qui me reste
du temps
je roulais dans le vignoble nantais
année dernière avec ma roue y'avait pas
de piste cyclable ni de trottoirs
j'étais dans la campagne et je roulais
sans casque ce que j'ai le droit
mais les gendarmes ont arrêté pour cette
raison en tout cas ils voulaient me
verbaliser parce que je ne portait pas
de casque je leur ai dit écoute et non
le casque n'est pas obligatoire
c'est comme en vélo ses conseillers
effectivement par contre effectivement
g1j un moteur mais je suis considéré
comme un piéton un super piétons en
quelque sorte donc vous pouvez me
verbaliser pour la raison que je suis
sur la route c'est que j'ai rien à faire
là voilà du coup j'ai reçu une
contravention de 4 euros piétons en
situation irrégulière heureusement que
les a un peu aidés parce qu'il avait du
mal à trouver le motif
tout ça pour dire que les règles du jeu
sont en train de changer
même les forces de l'ordre ne sont pas
encore très au courant donc voilà les
règles du jeu sont en train de changer
et j'espère que je vais vous croisez
prochainement sur ce grand terrain de
jeu qu'est la région parisienne pourquoi
pas vous aussi sur ce genre de petit ce
genre de petits véhicules
merci pour votre attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]